my name is Reuben I work as a customer
engineer within Google cloud out of the
Brussels office and the last three and a
half years I spent talking to a lot of
enterprises about chrome and Android and
in this session I want to talk to you
about chrome and Android in the
enterprise what we've achieved but also
what's what's next with with our
mobility solutions we think as Android
and chrome as the beginning point for a
lot of our cloud solutions if you look
at G suite or any application developed
on Google cloud our best access to
Android and chrome and we think that
they play well together now Before we
jump into the presentation I just wanted
to give you the momentum on both of
these platforms and it's quite American
to pull up a slide with a lot of numbers
but they're they're quite impressive if
you look at Android one point four
billion 30-day active users are using an
Android smartphone today consumers
enterprise third world a lot of people
are using Android today there's a one
about 1.5 million Android devices
activated daily so the rate is still
going up on the Android adoption in the
world so 80 about 82 percent of these
smartphones in the world out there are
android-based devices if you look at the
enterprise space and the Android share
is considerably lower than the 82
percent figure and we we want to grow
this number of course we want to grow
the market share of Android within the
enterprise space with a larger number
and we know we have a few challenges to
overcome that security batching issues a
lot of diversity of devices if you have
a Samsung device and a Sony divisor
they're completely different so we have
a few challenges to overcome in order to
grow that market share if we look at
Chrome and the first wave of adoption of
Chrome devices was in the consumer space
where even I I gave my mother a Chrome
device because every time at Christmas
Christmas she came to me to ask to wipe
her computer of all of the viruses or a
software issue and so on I just gave her
a chrome device with
a Google meal solution and it stopped
because basically all she does is going
to email do few doc documents calendar
PC banking and so on which is basically
all in the browser second wave of
adoption that we saw is in the education
space you might be aware of the
fifty-two percent market share that we
are getting in the American public
school sector where pupils are using
Chrome devices in order to get teaching
lessons and so on and what we see in the
last two three to two two to three years
is an adoption of chrome devices in the
enterprise space as well because of the
security and the simplicity of the
solution as well and a lot of
applications today are already
accessible through the through the web
browser so why would you still need a
Phat client with all of the management
capabilities about 800,000 Chromebooks
are sold to do the business annually and
again this is definitely a subject to to
to growth but a reality is much darker
if you look at the total amount of
workers 3.25 billion workers out there
that aren't still not connected to any
sort of device to sort of functionality
there's a 750 million pcs in business
that need to be replaced and about 300
million managed smartphone devices
there's definitely a opportunity for
chrome and Android to grow into that
space of course we can't do this alone
we do this with a lot of our partners
app developers OMS but also AI is vs
that are writing specifically
applications for for both of these
platforms so what do I want to cover in
this this presentation first of all
let's give you an overview of the
ecosystem
what is the ecosystem that both Android
and chrome can can benefit from let's
look at Android and Chrome in the
enterprise specifically device
management and security are notably the
two strongest topics on this in this
area and last but not least let's finish
off with some best practices and new
functionality coming up in in the Oh
Virgin the ecosystem I think the
strongest point on Android is the
application developer community that
exists on Android Android studio is one
of the most used
development platform for applications
for mobile applications if you look at
play sixty five billion applications are
installed as of today through the Google
Play environment and we basically offer
a good means for developers to monetize
on their applications on their
functionality but also for enterprises
to develop specific applications for
their employees and deliver them through
the Play ecosystem 1 million
applications plus applications are
available and of course these
applications are are actively used today
today this means that through the Google
Play services you can deliver those
applications on smartphones tablets and
any other form factor like Google
watches for example but also we've
opened up the Chrome ecosystem to be
able to run Play services on top of a
Chrome device so this basically means
that a Chrome device capable of running
play applications Android applications
is able to run these 1 million available
applications and this is very useful if
you have offline capabilities if you
need offline capabilities for example on
my work Chromebook I've enabled the Play
Store I downloaded the Netflix Android
applications and I'm able to watch
Netflix series offline on my Chrome
device but think of me in a more
professional environment but this gives
you a bit of a better understanding of
the capabilities of the chrome devices
applications are very important to us
and the huge success of Android is also
coming from the OEMs we've taken a bit
of a different approach than our main
competitor in this area where Android is
a very open system and can be adapted by
a lot of the OEMs to provide a specific
experience on our phones again a Samsung
device is quite different in a user
experience than a Sony or a pixel device
this openness really tries to the
ecosystem
but it gave us a lot of challenges as
well because well manageability and also
security becomes becomes a very
difficult difficult approach the most
use case today is is still the
our phone and the tablet but if you have
couriers from DHL or a post NL they
often use Android devices to scanning
your parcels as well we see Android
devices popping up in hospitals or just
for for nurses to be used for their
electronic patient files for example but
we see the device's ecosystem really
growing as well and we try to tackle a
lot of the issues that we saw with the
diversity in this platform we try to
tackle them on the chrome side as well a
lot of new form factors have been
launched as of lately the majority of
the use cases that we saw for Chrome
devices where in the connected worker
space people using a Chrome device to
access functionality or use the browser
in order to go into their applications
what we saw as well is that chrome is an
ideal platform for single application
purposes like kiosks and so on the a
open chrome box meaning for example is a
specifically designed device in order to
run digital signage or a single single
application for a very long time and
their industry great and they're
designed to run 24/7 and they're being
used in a lot of our in a lot of our
import enterprises the asus chromebox
for example is the PC form factor and
this is also being used a lot in digital
signage environments by the way the
largest deployment of chrome devices is
in in Europe is Toyota Motor Europe so
if you're entering a showroom of Toyota
and you see a large screen with the
latest cars it's actually driven by a
chrome device of course there's a huge
ecosystem behind it as well and the one
thing I definitely want to mention is
the management piece we work very
closely together with the incumbents in
the mobile device management space like
AirWatch blackberry MobileIron in order
to make sure that all of these devices
that enter into the enterprise space are
managed in a proper way the feedback
that we've gotten from those EMS is that
Android is hard to manage one of the
hardest thing to manage is that there's
no
consistent set of api's available for
Android devices if you look at lollipop
if you look at KitKat going further
along the stream there was always a
different way of managing these devices
and often they need a device owner
rights in order to manage that device
properly device owner rights is in
Windows term is just as administrator
rights you have access to everything on
that device we believe that that's not
secure so in collaboration with these
emm providers we've created a specific
set of api's on which you can manage the
device in the various various
constellations whether that's a
corporate-owned single-use case device
owner or a personal use is this plays
play a very important role as well and
we see that is v's developing android
enterprise specific features as well
like for example on Salesforce if you
deploy Salesforce in a work profile it
can act differently than a sales force
application enrolled in a personal space
very important aspect so I've been
talking about into Android Enterprise
let's look a bit at what we're trying to
achieve here I think that the strongest
point about Android is that we're coming
in from a consumer angle a lot of people
are using Android at home already
and want to take that experience into
the enterprise phase and this conflicts
quite a lot with the enterprise
organizations or organizations that want
to standardize or want a very secure
solution in that place if in a bring
your own device scenario most of the
organizations demand to have full
control over that that device whether
you want that or not it's it's quite
it's quite often didi case what we are
trying to do with Android Enterprise is
basically building those capabilities in
order to allow organizations to use
Android in a very secure and managed
managed way we started off with lollipop
and for those who are around for a
longer time we call the name Android for
work basically bringing Android for work
we decided to skip
to leave the Android for work part and
just keep it Android because it's
basically a standard set if you buy a
pixel phone today Android for work or
the Android enterprise capabilities are
building we started off with lollipop we
we gave the API so we described the
api's and and recommended to be used by
the OEMs
which gave a bit of a particular
situation because some phones support it
and some phones didn't support it so
there was a bit of ambiguity so we
didn't marshmallow we basically said
okay if you want to run Play services if
you want to ruin applications on top of
your smart phone you need to fulfill all
of the requirements that are needed to
run Android Enterprise as a reminder
Android enterprise are a standard set of
API vests that are can be used by an EMM
to manage those devices by AMM there
were two use cases one was BYOD so
basically bringing your own phone adding
in second profile which is managed by
the organization if you leave the
organisation you can wipe up that of
that profile and still use the personal
side and we also offer the corporate
corporate owned version as well so
basically having a phone that's being
provided by the enterprise completely
locked down for that aspect in nuga by
the way we also added requirement for
encryption for these devices any
marshmallow device out there has a
default encryption building into those
devices certainly from a security point
of view that's very strong nuga further
usability enhancement and management
there were a few hiccups with regards to
identity provision that's all being
solved and is very easy to be to be used
and of course we are still developing
more and more into the Oh release coming
up what does it look like if you're
looking at a personal device from a work
profile way if you're using G suite
today this is already available for you
to test out so if you have a marshmallow
and onwards Android device what you're
able to do is activate the work
and what it basically does is you have
your personal phone which is initiated
with your personal gmail address and you
do whatever you want on that phone
because that's a personal space but what
you're adding is a second profile on
that device which is completely managed
by the organization organization can put
applications into that can also require
a for example an additional pin code so
if you want to enter this this work
profile you need to enter its specific
pin code in order to access your work
applications but what's really neat
about this is the complete separation
between personal and work data from a
user perspective my favorite feature of
running this work profile is that I can
switch off the work profile when I'm at
home so I just drag down the Action List
tap on the work profile and all of my
work applications are grayed out no
notifications and if I get an incoming
call because my work profile is closed
it connect cannot access my work
contacts so I know that that might be
somebody from from work calling I'm
quite harsh on my my work-life balance
also it's independently lockable that's
what I that's what I explained as well
and a company can bring wipe wipe
remotely wipe all of the contents of
that phone without touching the personal
site on that domain that matter if we
look at corporate owned devices so these
are devices owned by corporate and then
given to a to a to an end-user we do
have some some very good good good
management capabilities in there
of course the reset wipe and manage
reset protection is in there and if
anybody has ever managed an Android
device and accidentally set up the
factory reset protection so I have a
customer who had 100 phones activated
with one gmail address some of them left
and then they wipe the whole device if
you want to reuse that device you need
to have the password of that personal
account so some of these devices became
game lockable with corporate-owned you
absolutely lose that you can also manage
the OTA update policy so if you want to
have your device's receive the
the greatest on on those devices and we
absolutely recommend it so Google has
done a great effort to separate out the
functionality updates from the security
update so functionality updates need to
go through a whole series of testing by
a carrier by no e/m before they can be
released to a phone with security
updates we have taken functionality away
so that carriers and OEMs can easily
apply these security settings and a lot
of these large corporations like Samsung
and blackberry are doing this for their
flagship flagship accounts and we
absolutely recommend if you're buying a
large bulk of devices to have this as a
requirement when you buy these these
devices another thing that plays into
mind when you're talking about
enterprise capability so you have the
device and default set of api's next
what we're offering in that in that
space is the Play managed play
environment so as an organization you
have a specific set of the Play Store
available in which you can whitelist the
applications you want to be using into
that work work environment from a
security point of view this is this is
quite quite unique because you are you
as an organization decide what
applications are running so you can make
the assessment whether an application is
a potential harmful application yes or
no there's no other way to install
applications into a work profile so that
takes away all of the all the risks of
having a potential harmful application
into your work profile the sources can
be public so you don't have to do any
application wrapping you just select the
application it can run on an enterprise
profile or you can host your apk at
Google or even at at your own premises
but you use the Google Play Store as the
application installation or application
delivery mechanism of course there's a
very close connection with the e MMS so
that you have a single source where your
manage all of this of course we deploy
them so the EMM
basically you whitelist the applications
from an EMM point of view you
the application silently install these
applications onto your phone or you can
have the Play Store as a self-service
portal so if ant user wants to install
books or Salesforce or whatever he's
able to do that because you as an
organization are allowing this control
the auto updates and what's also very
new is applying application
configurations to it as well so if you
deploy a mail client you already give it
a configuration with that mail client so
a user doesn't have to fill around with
any of these settings what is less known
is that Google Play plays a very
important aspect in the security
elements so if you're looking at the
Play services we basically do a lot on
the antivirus side of things so if you
look at the Play applications host that
within the Play Store we do static
controls so we basically run we check
the code base of an apk but we also do
dynamic testing of all of these
applications so basically running these
applications in a real-time environment
to check what an application is doing
and whether that application is exactly
doing what it says it does in that case
we can already take away a lot of these
applications that are basically
camouflaging all of the all of the
elements that they are doing we also
provide device scans per day so if
you're an Android user we basically scan
the device for you there's a lot of
applications and divides applications in
android and existing today this is
absolutely not necessary because we take
care of this this as well what is less
known is that we also check the image of
an android device as well so if you look
at the certification process I said well
if you want to run the Play services and
Google applications on top of an Android
device you need to fulfill a
certification or a set of requirements
because we do that we scan the image we
know exactly what the code base looks
like of a Samsung s6 out of 2014 with
carrier this so we have a lot of images
available of specific configurations if
somebody tries to route or
routed his device it has changed the
code base of the of the roam of the of
the of the system so what we basically
do is we have an attestation API that
can be called by for example a banking
application so if the ING application
calls and is at the station application
you can check whether the image that
application is running on is still the
verified one or not and based on that
information you can you can take away
the the installation so there's
definitely a lot happening on the on the
background Chrome OS again this this was
always so I I focused on the two
platforms so chrome and Android in the
enterprise space there's two different
use cases for this I had a lot of
questions around security on the Android
side with Chrome OS I won the heart of a
lot of security officers in such a sense
that some of the bank largest banks in
the UK the security officers were
running around with a chrome device
accessing Citrix because on the endpoint
there was absolutely no data that you
just used the Chrome device in order to
access the information on their own
back-end and it was a very very strong
point we've always covered Chrome OS on
on all four topics speed simplicity
security and shareability
because of its very very warm here I
will not go into a lot of details we're
all longing to a good cold drink
I am definitely one of them but I just
wanted to go over them very quickly
speed if you've ever used the Chrome
device it's just opening a lid waiting 6
seconds start typing and you have all of
the functionality that you ever need
I was a Mac user and before that I was a
Windows user there were times that I
opened up my laptop start push the power
button went for a coffee and maybe I was
in time to log in my to type in my
password what we've done is we stripped
down a version of Linux and made it so
that you can only run a browser on top
of it and with every release of Chrome
OS one thing that is very important is
that if we add additional functionality
it needs the Chrome OS needs to be
faster than the previous version if you
take an old Chromebook on version 24
updated to version
62-day the device will guarantee it will
burn faster gonna run smoother than than
then never for simple I already gave the
example of my mother and the only thing
she needs to do is log in with her gmail
address and she has access to it
and also I have been I've been playing
around with a lot of Technology but the
simplicity is still the one that really
grabs my mind secure as well because
it's a browser you can't install any
software any dll's or any applications
on top of it well basically this takes
away all of the potential harmful
applications basically we are even
challenging the hacker community on
Chrome OS to hack into Chrome OS if you
try to if you find a vulnerability and
we verified it we will pay you $100,000
in order to to to prove this district
and and trust me there's a lot of people
trying to do that but today the track
record is completely clean shareability
there's a lot of use cases so if you
look at the information worker who has
his own laptop or his own Chromebook ok
shareability is not a big issue but if
for example my Chromebook breaks down
and I login to my colleagues one that's
that's perfectly fine because what you
do every time you login into your Chrome
device it creates a root directory or it
creates a directory for that user which
is encrypted by that user's username and
password there's no notion of an admin
there's no notion of somebody who can
access that that information other than
the user that has that username and
password what's very neat about this
shareability aspect is that with a
managed environment so for example with
a huge project with it with a UK bank
where employees who are logging in with
their bank account it's a completely
lockdown environment no video camera no
microphones no SD cards only Citrix can
run as a plugin that's the only thing it
can do it can access Citrix that's it
but if he logs out logs in with his
gmail address here's a full completely
working Chrome device in front of it so
highly regulated industries and also the
freedom of using you
your own username on that device of
course this is completely manageable as
well let's talk about applications on
Chrome devices and one of the strongest
point or about 80% of a project I've
been working on
we're always related with virtualization
software and we believe that
virtualization software is a stepping
stone into a fully cloud-based workplace
and our end goal is of course that had
all of the applications you access is
through a browser VMware and Citrix and
the other cloud they have provides some
solutions in order to provide
functionality into a browser Citrix and
VMware are the most advanced one and
basically what you're able to do is swap
out your thin clients and use a Chrome
device instead and we freed up a lot of
employees from being tied behind a desk
with a thin client and one screen and a
keyboard and a mouse to a Chrome device
that they can take carry with them in
meeting meeting rooms or can go into
another office with their own personal
personal device this works quite quite
well of course the one thing that I that
I didn't mention is the availability of
the of the play applications or the
Android applications on top of Chrome
what we've done here is a bit of a
specific implementation of containers so
there's basically an Android device
running on chrome bare metal and we've
intertwined the interface so that it's
really a one that it's just one one
interface so it doesn't matter whether
you're accessing a windows-based
applications through virtualization a
native web application or an Android
application it all looks the same to to
the end-user what's particularly
interesting about chrome is the
connection with the device management
and the device management basically
allows you to control any aspect of a
chrome device from the hardware side so
from the device side from a remote point
of view you can change the behavior of
the device within any second so if you
want to say okay this person has moved
into a different role or he has little
less access to applications you can
basically limit that immediately by
changing some
of these these aspects what's very nice
as well as you that you can buy from any
source so any commercially available
Chrome device if you if you if you buy
them they act as a just a consumer
device once you've enrolled them into
the management console you gain complete
access to it so configuring a device and
we've seen that in many cases takes
quite less time before that they grab
the they took out the chrome the laptop
they install the specific image they
start to installing software and then
after half a day they can give the
laptop to to an employee now in this
case they just grabbed the Chrome device
tap ctrl alt e login with an admin or a
user that is known within the device and
you can ship that out to to an end user
because in that case this is completely
managed remote lock and automatic
security of course so if you leave a
chrome device on the train well the data
on the device is already minimal because
you use the browser and downloading
applicants oft we're downloading data is
not really happening but using the
encryption on the user level a diva data
thief cannot get access to that from an
equation Krypton point of view and even
if it tries to take out the hard disk
and try to put out the property in
another hard disk into that Chrome
device the device won't boot because the
hard disk is known as a known
configuration within that within Chrome
OS it's very very very very complex in
that case native security Hardware day
in every Chrome device there's a TPM
trust the platform model chip we provide
the operating system and updates again a
bit different than the Android side and
we're trying to copy a lot of the chrome
side into the into the Android side so
we as guru every six weeks there's a new
version of Chrome OS no matter what kind
of device you're using whether it's a
Chromebook flip a chrome a chrome bit or
chrome base it's one one code base it's
just one one operating system we have a
profound use of sandboxing as well
basically meaning that every service
runs in its own sandbox and can only
give access or has access to certain
data particles or
programs on the device by by by just by
policy so let's look at a few of the
backs best practices so if we're looking
at mobile device management we see four
or mobile devices we see for access and
let's start in the left lower corner
with an unmanaged device an unmanaged
device is just a feature phone or phone
that's being used and is not connected
to the enterprise in any way one
abstract layer on top of that is
basically the personal usage of of a
device adding a work profile on top of
it now the best practice in this is that
the minimal requirement that we
recommend is marshmallow marshmallow
devices have android enterprise
capabilities built-in have that android
a work profile by default in there in
there in there api's so this basically
allows organizations to have the EMM
manage that work profile on top of it
the second layer on top of that is a
managed device this is a corporate old
personal enabled device basically the
organization or the employer is in
charge of this this device again
marshmallow is the least least operating
system that we recommend in that case
because of the standard encryption and
also of the addition of the default API
is in that case laws will not leave the
dedicated devices within the android
android enterprise capabilities we've
also added kiosk usage into the android
images and the AP is basically giving it
consistent management of single
applications on those device so think of
a tablet running just one single
application at kiosk in shops for
example or for digital signage this is
this is edit as well do not use unknown
sources and force verify apps there's
still a major EMM that requires the user
to set to turn off this this feature if
you ever downloaded from Chrome browser
or any browser apk
if you try to install that on Android it
will give you a warning saying hey you
cannot install this because this is an
unverified application we always
recommend installing applications from
the Play Store because of the reasons I
just explained is that we do a lot of
research we do a lot of testing on the
application so we think that play and
certainly the white listed applications
in play are the most secure way to to
use to these applications so please do
not set the policy that unknown sources
cannot be switched off it's a default
policy require device encryption of
course I cannot stress on this if you
leave a phone on the train you want to
make sure that the device is encrypted
by default and we've done a lot of work
in order to make sure that personal and
business data is separately separately
encrypted as well enforce minimal
security update policies again if you're
buying a lot of devices please make sure
that the OEM you are buying from is
guaranteeing that you get monthly
updates security updates we try to be
the the best pupil in the class so if
you buy a pixel phone we guarantee that
at least two years you will receive a
monthly security updates for these
devices as well and a lot of the OEMs
are following this as well because they
see that security is very important in a
lot of lot of case separate management
of work and personal data again from a
user perspective
personally I quite like the separation
of work and personal data because I know
that what I do in my personal set is
completely separated from my data from
my work for my work profile again if
you're working with a lot of photos some
photos you don't want to end up in the
work profile of course I use the latest
available management API so what's next
so what's legs I've talked about a few
use cases so bring your own device so
you have your personal profile with a
work profile on top of it which is
managed by the organization well some of
our and some of our customers says we
want it the other way around we have a
corporate owned device and we want to
enable a person
no profile to it so that the user can
still do it but we remain 100% in
control over the complete phone so
that's something that we were launching
in in oh so this will basically allow
users to add their own personal profile
for it in a corporate owned device still
maintaining the whole data separation on
top of it we are probably not using the
work profile icon it will be something
different because then it's the other
way around it might be confusing if you
want to access personal information
through an application that has a work
badge on it so that that would that will
probably probably go away what we're
doing in oh as well is separately
encrypt the data from the work profile
and the personal space again in case you
want to wipe a device in that case you
just have to throw away the encryption
key of the personal of the work site so
that any any any application or any data
cannot be accessed afterwards we are
adding new privacy notices and corporate
devices a huge feedback because if
you're working on a work managed or a
work profile device some of the
capabilities on the personal side can be
switched off as well we've added the
capabilities to add some some help notes
as well so basically say okay your
corporation has switched of this setting
because of this or you can contact your
you can contact your own your own
organization this is quite handy as well
so basically if you lose your phone in
Android by default you are able to say
okay this phone is for me with a phone
number so that people can return the
phone if they haven't stolen it this can
be set on by corporate policy as well so
basically saying okay this is the
Service Desk if you find this phone
please return it to to this to this
organization device provisioning the
second topic so security in Android
second topic was device provisioning the
other phone manufacturer out there
that's that's competing with Android has
a very very neat mechanism you just
provide the serial number and once the
user
opens of the oars boots that phone it's
automatically enrolled within within
within the EMM for example with Android
that's quite different because we don't
own the hardware of that device we don't
know what the device is and we don't
know who it's who it's attached to what
we are trying to work on a way in order
to mimic that situation and you will see
that with pixel phones already if you
buy a pixel phone in bulk you provide
you get a set of emi e numbers which you
can upload into a portal and once that
device boots up the device will be
automatically enrolled within the mobile
device management management console
we're working on QR codes as well so if
you can scan a code and it will
automatically enroll NFC tokens as well
is something that's available in the
near future word profile improvements
verify apps strict mode stricter
enforcement of verify applications and
verify application this is our antivirus
solution so we're we're extending that
functionality in a lot more phones so
basically able to scan those phones at
any time at any place and new api's will
be available as well
I basically man I mentioned this as well
on the chrome site this is a device that
will will come out in Europe quickly as
well this is the new flagship chrome
devices the Samsung Chrome device
they're re-entering the chrome market
and this is a premium two-in-one Chrome
Chromebook offering we often get the
question like you have Android and you
have Chrome as a platform why maintain
both what we think that Android is great
for mobility for Internet of Things for
smaller devices to consumer information
we think chrome is more of a
Productivity platform and what you will
be seeing there was a huge strict
separation between tablets and chrome
devices there was never a chrome tablet
we are now investigating on
reinvestigating that that aspect so in
the first face you will see this this
sort of convertible so you can use this
as a tablet and we've done a lot of work
to have the stylus working very well on
a Chrome device I see in the near future
that you could
work on some detachable or even on a
chrome Chrome device and this is very
useful in kiosk usage because you have a
very strong secure device a very
shareable device but still have that
mobility grasp as well with with Chrome
OS it's quite a nice device a big
announcement as well is with VMware so
viewer offers virtualization software so
you have virtual applications that can
run on a Chrome device as well the
Chrome device management piece was
something you could only buy from Google
so you buy a license and you can manage
the Chrome device what we've done is
we've opened up that device management
capabilities by opening up the api's and
what VMware has done is they have
incorporated these API into their device
management capabilities so if you
already have a VMware workspace one
environment you now can manage these
devices through that workspace as well
and we see a lot of new things popping
up as well new ways of managing devices
as well
Active Directory for example is a lot
used within the enterprise space a lot
of people are not yet in the Google
ecosystem so we're trying of looking for
simpler ways of managing Chrome devices
out of the active directory for example
opening up a lot of a lot of new news
new cases so to conclude the session I
hope it was useful first of all thanks
for staying in the room even if it's
that when it's now 36 degrees if you
want to test drive the Android
management experience or if you want to
verify what your EMM is telling is the
truth there's the Android management
experience so if you look at this link
and I think these slides will be will be
shared it basically allows you to have
the managed Android experience without
all setting up all of the management
capability so it's a very useful way to
test out all of these these api's and if
you're really interested in the
connected workspaces in where the cloud
meets the devices and I invite you to
look at this this connected workspaces
Bates as well which shows a bit more the
capabilities of what's possible and
what's next with that with these devices
so thank you very much and I hope you
enjoyed it and let's go for a drink
[Applause]